we're standing here at the Villa Russian
Ukrainian border here as you can see the
Villa Russians have set up barbed wire
on the other side just a few meters away
is Ukraine and they have set up
barricades
the Belarus Ukraine border has been a
strategic location for Russia since it's
invaded Ukraine a year ago when Russian
troops mounted attacks from here now as
Kiev warns of a renewed Russian
offensive tensions along this 620 mile
long Frontier are ratcheting up renewing
fears in Kiev and the west of a possible
joint attack on Ukraine the biela
Russian state border committee invited
us on a rare visit to see what's
happening here
in recent weeks along this border Biola
Russian forces have been holding joint
combat drills with Russian troops and on
the other side Ukraine's military has
been reinforcing defenses
the border patrol says that there has
been a lot of tension at this particular
border which is closed at the moment
they say that sometimes drones fly over
Ukrainian forces have admitted to such
activity to monitor for potential new
attacks questions
thoughts on the Bella Russian side are
keeping a close eye on the border
others are training to intercept any
unauthorized Crossings
officials say they think Ukraine May
launch an attack
Ukraine has dismissed its assertion
um
an authoritarian ruler and a close Ally
of Russian President Vladimir Putin said
in recent days that he would again let
Russian troops use Belarus to launch
attacks on Ukraine but he said he has no
intention of sending his own troops
there though he warned of one important
exception is
foreign
military action would likely come with
challenges for lukashenka Belarus has a
small army they are not tested and
moreover polls show that yellow Russians
do not have an appetite for war
but some dealer Russians are supporting
Russia in other ways here at the yellow
Russian women's Union people have been
Gathering boxes of donations of supplies
food medicine for people in donbass who
they say are suffering and need the help
Vladimir kasbanov is the business
manager of the Alexei to life Foundation
where volunteers work to send supplies
to pro-russian parts of Ukraine's
Eastern dombash region is
colleagues say they try to stay out of
politics and that the suffering of the
war transcends borders
lukashenko said that his country is
willing to offer more assistance to
quote our Russian brother in the war
against its cross-border neighbor but
has dismissed claims by Kiev that Putin
can pressure him to take a more direct
role in the conflict yes
thank you
[Music]